if Pop has had bad words hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode 120 today
we're gonna talk about social media as
you probably know yeah the social media
is yeah all of them she talked about her
weekend first Wow yeah sure how was your
weekend my weekend was solid man
although I was supposed to go out to
Montana I didn't work out though because
Ella and Becks were both sick at the
same time and we're getting ready to
film some stuff and I couldn't afford to
get sick and so okay yeah we spent the
weekend apart but we're back together
and Becks is still sick and now I'm
terrified nice how about how about that
sports ball game and sports vault
believe it or recording this shortly
after the Super Bowl
have you seen do I'm gonna put this in
the notes bin there is a video of this
do it was it's an old video but it's
this dude who's like he's just wearing a
jacket and it has like a football emblem
basketball on one side baseball
basketball on the other side of softball
or something and then it's a sports
jacket and it's this dude going on it
he's just mocking people who get so
invested with the team and it's just
hilarious because I used to be that guy
I mean I said like Cincinnati Bengals
season tickets man and like I mean like
if they lost a game did he used to ruin
my week but it's funny cuz like watch it
this video with this dude I'm like oh
this it's really ridiculous for me to be
that upset over who lost or won a
football game well I think I think
Seinfeld is the one who said you're not
you're not rooting for a team you're
rooting for a Jersey yeah I was the
opposite when I was growing up was huge
you tell jazz fan as most of you know
who've been listening to this podcast
for a while but really I wasn't a Utah
Jazz in as much as I was a John Stockton
and Karl Malone fan yeah and had they
been traded to the Minnesota
Timberwolves I would have very quickly
become a menace Oh
Timberwolves right and I think that some
people were that way with Jordan or or
they're certain players Blake Griffin
just got traded from the LA Clippers to
to the Detroit Pistons and I'm sure
there's some people are like I really
like Blake and now I'm a Detroit piston
absolutely same thing happen when Brahm
went to the Eden back to the Cleveland
yeah yeah yeah well and and there was a
weird thing about that though because
they the people in Cleveland felt like
LeBron had completely dissed their city
yeah I can't believe you left us and
then they're like thanks for coming back
here's the weirdest thing though what
about after the Super Bowl I didn't
watch any of the Super Bowl I saw two
commercials from it which we could talk
about but I right after Super Bowl
people in Philadelphia were rioting
because they won well dude I don't know
if you know this or not actually this is
someone the other day I was like I was
telling them these stats and they were
like yeah man those stats are from 2014
and I was like like a lot this stuff I
gotta like really look at my set so I
don't know if this is still the case or
not so that's why I'm practicing it but
the Philadelphia Eagles they had the
courtroom in their Stadium so you could
let fans who got rowdy they were
arrested booked tried and thrown in jail
before the game was over no yes oh yeah
that is how like Philadelphia and
Oakland are like known for the two being
the two most like rowdy I mean in my
opinion I guess I'm pretty sure that
Utah Jazz had to be the exact opposite
fans yeah whenever we go they like if a
basketball goes in the crowd they gently
hand it back to the referee or whatever
whenever we go to Utah like the crowds
there are the nicest people that we ever
encounter there in Canada yeah and we
didn't have nice crowds no matter where
we go I mean it's it tends to be good
people it's tough Philadelphia they were
rioting outside of our admit like I'm
trying to like make sense of that and
like I just I thought well because I
think mob mentality
well definitely mom mentality but I
guess like what is it that causes a
group of people to celebrate something I
know my mentality but how does the mob
get that mentality like we're gonna
celebrate in Vice by showing our
celebration we're gonna do it by ruining
the city I think the same thing is
consumerism it's the lowest common
denominator and so crowds congregate
around a purpose and if they don't have
a purpose though the purpose is found
and that purpose can be rioting or
violent or say like we're gonna go and
help the homeless tonight it butts a lot
of crowds congri and do that right if
we're gonna go and say the animals on
the street tonight yeah you're right
they do
there's 58,000 homeless people in Los
Angeles County and there are crowds of
people who will go down to skid row
downtown and and help out and because
the crowd congregates around a common
purpose now if you just get a crowd to
go down there a bunch of Philadelphia
Eagles fans after a game and they don't
have a purpose well then all of a sudden
you've got trouble broom because they're
looking for a purpose and when we we're
blindly searching for a purpose within a
crowd instead of looking back at our own
individual values then all of a sudden
it can devolve really quick because
someone does something you're like okay
I guess I need to congregate around that
person's actions and interests and
values and then I think everything just
sort of it goes off it goes off the
rails did you see the the Superbowl
commercial with the the RAM truck the
Martin Luther King commercial dude oh
man I'm just I don't know if I want to
talk about this controversy because it's
it is so stupid I did see it well let's
talk about I because I was I was torn on
it a torn about it at first because for
III I hereby announce that I don't want
anyone using my voice or likeness after
I'm dead to sell products yeah that's a
problem however a hundred and what 12
million people hundred eleven million
people are watching this game and a lot
of them have are young and have no idea
or just a vague idea who Martin Luther
King is and maybe they knew the I have a
dream speech right but that beyond that
that they really didn't know much about
him and and actually February 4th was
the 50th anniversary of the speech they
used in that commercial so in a way that
they were commemorating the memory
absolutely of more
with their king they were yes they were
coming from a you know ostensibly it is
a good place like they weren't they
weren't looking at it and saying oh man
let's let's let's cause a big hubbub
about us commercializing dr. Martin
Luther King right so I'm gonna play the
Martin Luther King commercial but then I
have a second commercial to play someone
edited the commercial and what we'll
play that really quick let's have a
listen okay if you want to be wonderful
if you want to be
but recognize that he who is greatest
among you shall be your citizens
that's the new definition of greatness
by given definition of greatness it
means that everybody can be great you
don't have to
[Music]
so generated by love
alright so then at the end of the
commercial right there it says built to
serve RAM and yeah and so so here's
here's the thing I think that wait I
still want to see the second video you
were about to but both thought about
this first so we just watched that and
we'll put a link to both of these videos
in the show notes because I think part
of it you have to see the visuals that
go along with it you can hear it here on
on the podcast but here's the thing I
feel like it was really well done
inspirational commercial and it tugs at
the heartstrings very much man but the
end of the day they're still trying to
sell you this product but ok ok if I may
I'm not trying to defend dodge here by
the way we're just having a conversation
about you do defend them yeah I know and
they may be worth defending here yeah I
know you don't care um but yeah I'm just
trying to figure this out with you so
they are um they're they are trying to
meet what that commercial what that said
to me was yeah we are an American made
company mm-hmm
we care about American lives and we go
out of our way to serve the American
people with our product mm-hmm that is
how that is how I took I took that it is
a little weird at the end where it's
like built to serve yeah well and you
guys have a program called built to
serve right is the sort of so so it is a
in its in in in dude anything racial
like the tension in this country is it's
absurd man yeah it's it's crazy so I
don't think so man I really don't Matt's
social media which we're gonna talk
about today and I think it's it's the
news which by the law no it isn't it but
that's but that's but that's where I was
getting who's the comedian this he
doesn't he every time someone says then
instead of the when he says the news he
says the bad news
I was watching the bad news today that's
hilarious and because that's really what
it is what it is I mean there are there
are a few exceptions there's that that
organ
good remember we met with the founder of
good a few years ago back in 2012 yeah
good good magazine those guys are great
yeah it was like good news
Yeah right right but that's the thing
had that they were trying to find an
antidote and that's not nearly as
popular as the breaking bad news from
Brennan or is NBC or fox or whatever
where I was going with the racial
tension thing is that there certainly
are racial tensions in in in this
country and I guess the news the media
and it's not just the media I mean there
are and it's not just racial tensions
it's anything that is that has tension
right now people go out of their way to
I'm trying not to sound like a complete
jerk right here man
all right Josh I'm gonna say this and
then you help me unpack it but like III
don't I think people go out of their way
to get triggered yeah they go out of
their way to get offended and to make
every thing as right as possible let's
just say some people some people yeah
did I say everyone no you said people
okay yeah I some people so so but that
said um with this Martin Luther King
dodged at the end of the commercial bill
to serve we obviously see what they did
there but there could be a different
connotation with that commercial if you
really go out of your way to look at
someone it's just like with the
minimalists we don't have a very minimal
amount of people who download this
podcast we don't have a very minimal
amount of people who limit it are the
first 100 people to download I I'm will
charge a million dollars of podcast no
but my point is is like with anything in
life there is no rule as I'm saying this
this is true there's no rule that's
gonna be a hundred percent accurate all
the time right there there is not
there's not going to be there's never
going to be an opportunity missed for
irony and in anything really yeah I
don't think does that make sense it does
absolutely and there there's certainly
irony in this and you brought up the
racial tension side I wasn't even
thinking about race II I mean Martin
Luther King to me
is a is a one it's time when he was
provocative and and there was certainly
a lot of racial tension then it doesn't
mean there isn't some now I don't think
it's as bad as a sixties of course no no
I don't think it's as blown out of
proportion as as people think it is
there was a so I think of psychologists
and I think it was the 1950s who who
took this Chinese couple all around the
United States they stayed in over 200
hotels and different cities and and then
they ate at different restaurants in
these small cities and small towns and
afterward after he did that he called up
each of the establishments and asked him
hey would you let a chinese couple stay
at your establishment mm-hm and oh yeah
I saw everyone except one said no of
course we wouldn't this is the we don't
let Chinese people say it but they
stayed there and no one had an actual
problem and I think social media in a
way is doing the same thing now where
the it people are picking teams and in a
very dangerous way picking teams and the
this term has come out identity politics
and to me that is it's so dangerous to
associate ourselves with a team just
because we were born in a particular way
if you're born of European descent or
African descent or Asian descent or my
team is German and your team is Scottish
or my team is Russian and your team is
Portuguese or whatever it's a weird way
to do it and I think that's the
unhealthy side of tribalism I think most
tribalism is actually unhealthy whether
it's nationalism or it is well what when
you are when you are 100 percent
tribalism or Nash or nationalists it's
like if you live and die by that tribe
then you're you're going to you're gonna
hurt some other people along the way
what's the thing we just talked about
with with the Philadelphia Eagles right
the the mob mentality that becomes a
tribe although I will argue that most
sports teams following that it's
relatively innocuous right you might be
it might be silly to some people or
whatever and I don't I don't really
follow sports much more i watch
basketball still but just occasionally
but i don't really fall along that much
but i'll tell you
this man like it's it's healthy
competition for the most part right
there there are really dangerous
competitions where if I win you lose and
all of a sudden you're homeless kind of
thing right but but most most friendly
competitions like that they can that we
can find some sort of meaning or purpose
in them right at least some joy from
those and I think where we get caught up
is we get caught up in in the my tribe
is better than your tribe and then we
identify with I I'm okay with tribalism
if it if it congregates around ideas
because you can choose to participate in
those ideas instead of like well my
tribe is for everyone who's six foot two
or taller
that's the tribe I'm in yeah I I'm all
for tribes in general as long as they
are not interfering with other people's
well-being yeah I think that's fair and
I think the problem with with tribes is
a lot of the time a lot of it does it
does affect the wall by default yeah
and so it's our our tribes out there
lake because let's look at the other
side of the coin there are tribes out
there who absolutely do not do that
right yeah we had again going back to to
the sports teams and or going back to
ideologies you know I don't know that
minimalism is necessarily an ideology
because there isn't a a inherent set of
rules or beliefs necessarily but we
could call it living a meaningful life
with less maybe that's the only inherent
rule or prescription but even that is
relatively nebulous and so I think we
can form a tribe around ideas but when
we form a tribe around bad ideas then we
tend to get bad results right and so
yeah I think overall tribalism is is bad
back to this commercial so we saw this
this Ram commercial we just listened to
it and it's a it's an inspirational
speech he's saying you you can be the
best version of yourself basically
someone and I can really appreciate this
took that same commercial and dubbed in
Martin Luther's king's speech about
anti-consumerism oh that's good because
he was an anti-consumerist right
that's genius and so you take the same
commercial right come over here we'll
take a look at this we'll put a link to
it in the show notes as well now the
presence of this instinct explains why
we are so often taken by advertisers you
know those gentlemen of massive verbal
persuasion and they have a way of saying
things to you that kind of get you in
the bind in order to be a man of
distinction you must drink this whiskey
in order to make your neighbors envious
you must drive this type of car in order
to be lovely to love you must wear this
kind of lipstick err this kind of
perfume and you know before you know it
you just find that stuff I got to drive
this car because it's something about
this car that makes my car a little
better than my neighbor's car I am sad
to say that the nation in which we live
is the supreme culprit and I'm going to
continue to say it to America what's
wrong with me man I'm not I feel bad for
Dodge right now I I don't know I just
listened to that I had I literally got
chills man it's a great speech and part
of it is I've been working on this damn
advertisements si I've never worked
longer on in fact one of our books we
wrote quicker than this si I've been
working on for three or four months now
since November and it's it's called can
we have an honest conversation about
advertisements and at its bloated zenith
it was a eight or nine thousand close to
nine thousand words and it's trimmed
down to about four thousand I hope to
make it a little bit less than that even
now but I've done a lot of research of
just and about advertising and and
trying to have an honest conversation
about it because yeah to me I want to
take this speech that we just heard and
make a minimalist commercial that in the
end of it instead of it says built to
serve RAM or whatever it just says
advertisements suck yeah and because
that's I want you see that yeah that
would be great man and and so maybe we
do a Kickstarter campaign see if we can
a few million dollars to do a Super Bowl
commercial yeah I don't think they'd let
us air something that says
advertisements suck and that is what God
could um
that would be awesome it would be great
house is a comfort how much would it
cost of Superbowl commercial I know it's
probably two three five million dude I
wonder if our audience would help us do
that man that would be that would be
incredible yeah but they do have to get
approved is the problem right right the
other thing we could maybe do a
billboard something like that but in the
same token though dude Lake so we're
talking about getting into the
advertisement realm to be ironic with it
and to be funny but do we even I mean
even to get in there dude I don't know
well here's the thing it would be it
would be very funny but I would really
have to give that a lot of consideration
because buying a billboard yeah
it is you're still feeding the machine
that you're fighting against yeah I have
a whole section of you call a chapter in
this essay about the usefulness of
advertisement but also how the pros
probably don't outweigh the cons and for
me yes it would be ironic or funny but I
the hope is to start a conversation
around the fact that advertisements are
pernicious yeah but that but the more I
think I'm sorry they don't up to you
dude no I I mean but I I think that's
what they did with remaking this
commercial yeah is to me that that
speech about the advertisements was just
as as powerful when it was more powerful
because the juxtaposition against the
commercial if you buy this car then
you'll be happy kind of thing and all of
a sudden it's like wait a minute this
the original commercial was not Martin
Luther King's vision of capitalism
Ramar ISM he had completely opposite
thoughts like yeah like it is a yeah
like that commercial is yeah talking
about irony edits and it's precipitously
well so if you want to do a commercial
like that I would encourage you not to
use Martin Luther King who was that
Jeremy Piven or get a Nick Lachey
mentioning to people and Cincinnati Bell
commercials but uh you can you could see
like people like that
are totally fine with the advertisement
and okay that I'm not judging them for
that no the problem is what what was
expressed here these were not Martin
Luther King's values and I think that's
where where it gets sticky
dude we have I believe where we add on
the intro shown like 45 minutes we
should probably get into these voicemail
questions what do you think yeah I think
so our first question is from Xander in
Orlando I had a couple questions for you
guys
regarding what you're finding out so far
now they're taking a break from social
media it's a point of contention I think
for quite a number of people especially
people that have business on the
internet and have social media accounts
that their business feeds off of I think
part of what you guys do is similar to
some of the stuff that I'd like to get
into I do
aspire to have my own podcast and stuff
like that I'm wondering what you're
finding so far how you're how you're
able to better utilize social media cuz
I know that's what you're planning on
doing for this for this new year and I
think it's a brilliant idea so that's
what I wanted to ask you how is it going
so far what are you finding and if you
do have some suggestions on how people
can use social media for the better
while in a sense minimizing your use on
it and making it more purpose purposeful
what would some of those tips be so one
Sanders referencing is during January
2018 Ryan and I and of course Jessica
who helps curate our our social media
feeds we took a break from social media
we deleted all of our tweets we so clean
slate there we delete all of our photos
from Instagram which is really difficult
twitter is easy you there's a program
you can you can basically just delete
all your past tweets we saved all of
them so we have our minimal man I'd love
to see know the confusion oh yeah really
what's happening well that's the other
thing we did so if we recorded this
video with our good friend Matthew Vela
of the ground up show podcast he also
directed our
minimalism he he he did this little
wasn't maybe thirty second forty second
clip of us giving this big announcement
and all of a sudden the screen starts
fading a little bit and we're looking
into the camera and then it fades to
this static and the rest of the message
is just static and the people look like
oh my god we're all your pictures go and
Ron had so many people messaged us that
day and they were like I wanted to go
back and look at your your past your
past photos and I'm like just let go
it's okay it's okay
yeah there's enough yeah they're all
gone you can't go back and look at them
hopefully you enjoyed them while they
were there right and and that was a
really a metaphor more than anything
else but right what I'd like to do is
read the essay that we published about
that and then you and I can have
hopefully a meaningful conversation
around this essay and feel free to stop
and stop me pause me if if need be and
we can stop and talk about these these
individual lessons that we learned so
this is from our website we'll put a
link to this in the show notes it's
called how the minimalists are using
social media in 2018 have you ever quit
social media for an extended period of
time how did it change your perspective
after using social media almost every
day for the last seven years we decided
to walk away for a month
to see what would happen so on December
31st 2017 before the ball dropped we
deleted all of our past tweets and
Instagram photos we ceased our Facebook
and Pinterest activity and we uploaded a
cryptic video alluding to our
disappearance then we were gone and now
a month later we're still alive and
we're entering February 2018 with a
blank slate during our month away we
learned some important lessons and we
unlearned a few bad habits most
important we discovered a need for us to
use social media differently going
forward lessons learned purpose for us
once we created a blank slate the
purpose of social media became evident
communication not to sound overly
simplistic but we want to use these
platforms whether that's Twitter or or
Facebook or Pinterest or Instagram
want to use these platforms to
effectively communicate our thoughts
ideas and creations and to engage with
our audience directly via questions and
answers not broadcast our every thought
and I think that's that that is the key
here I think quite often social media is
used and it has even been used by us at
times to broadcast things that don't
require the they don't require being
broadcast at all
they're not serving the greater good in
a way right and so social media can be a
noisy place and we don't want to add to
the noise we want to whisper to the
people who are listening and that was
that was key for me and because I
remember when I first started doing
Twitter especially professionally
whatever that means we started the
minimalist like I did want to sort of
announce every thought because we had
the small audience of several hundred
people at that point not even a thousand
followers but I wanted to hey here's
what I'm thinking right now and I think
it's so important that you need to hear
about it as well but I think these days
I'm less concerned about every thought
being heard and instead I want to
communicate broader ideas and I think
social media can help augment that in a
way yeah definitely
the next lesson here is mindfulness
whenever an activity occupies much of
our mind we need to take a step back and
assess whether it's worth the time we
spend on that activity our friend
Jessica Lynn Williams who helps us
organize our social feeds discovered an
important insight without the pall of
social media in her everyday life step
in here's a quote from her she said this
to me on the phone actually stepping
away from social in January gave me the
clarity of mind to see quote the [ __ ]
in my mind running amok close quote as
Dan Harris says and it has prompted me
to adopt a regular meditation practice
which is something I've been afraid of
for a while this year will be the year I
take back my mind so that was from
Jessica and I found that fascinating
that the stepping back allowed her to to
get some clarity of mine and what I
really hope is that she's able to
continue that and so I'm gonna stay in
touch with her make sure
that she is able to maintain that
clarity of my eye not only do I not want
to clutter my own mind and your mine or
Shawn's mind but Jessica as well and and
of course the people who follow us on
social media as I said in the previous
paragraph we don't want to add to the
noise we want to whisper to the people
who are listening right absolutely the
next lesson here is augmentation we want
to use social media to augment our
creations blog podcast books films not
as the main platform on which we create
while we'll be active on the different
platforms it's worth noting that the
best place to follow the minimalists
isn't on social media the best place to
follow our creations is by subscribing
to our blog or by subscribing to our
podcast or both social media will simply
append those platforms so Xander here he
asked the question about that and the
thing I wrote down when I was listening
to his question Ryan is social media
seems to be getting in the way of his
creations he says I'm aspiring to start
a podcast no one that ever started a
podcast by aspiring right there might be
aspiration all over your apartment
Xander but but you haven't started the
podcast started a podcast all you need
is your laptop and and you can start
recording you can use the microphone on
your your cheap little headphones or
whatever and you can start a podcast
that way Ryan and I haven't always had
this podcast studio that we're in now in
fact we haven't even had it for a full
month yet and and so you don't have to
wait till all the conditions are right
and if social media is getting in the
way the thing that I like to think about
Ryan here is is the 8020 rule right I
think quite often we spend 80% of our
time working on social media and 20% of
the time creating and that is so
bass-ackwards
horrible man and so really the the the
when we use social media we should use
it to augment what we are whatever we
are creating whether that's a podcast or
a book or my friend Eric and in Dayton I
don't know if he he works at pres yeah
and he created that I just put it up on
my Instagram this morning he created
this beautiful bear
or Ella if you just check it out at
Joshua fields Millburn it's handmade is
one of one made in Dayton Ohio and he
built this bear over the weekend used
this Italian wool it's super soft and at
the end of the post I put this is not an
ad I paid full price for this bear and
that's a creation right and you can tell
if you go to his social media feeds he
uses that to to to augment his grace to
display his creations to the world
because marketing is the the final step
of the the creating process sure gotta
let people know about it but when it
takes over and all you're doing is just
marketing look at me look at me look at
me look at me your creations suffer so
when I think about old jobs I have old
corporations nice work for ya
the question that they asked going back
to that 20 80 percent you know you could
look at look at it this way to 20
percent of the time they're asking how
can we have a better product how can we
create a better customer experience 80
percent of the time they're like how can
we shove into people's faces more yeah
how can we get this in front of more
eyeballs how can we get more advertising
dollars like very little infrastructure
budget is talked about it's it was
always marketing it was never about
creating a better product or creating a
better experience for the customer it
was always about like fighting you know
fighting for how much how much marketing
dollars I can get from my department how
do I get this mediocre product in front
of his exact I make this mediocre
product look awesome
yeah so we can make our month or make
our quarter and that again is is
bass-ackwards yeah it's a it's a it's a
recipe for for disaster long term it may
work in the short term you may make more
money this month or this quarter you may
squeeze more blood out of a turnip but
next year two years from now five years
from now you're gonna feel great about
about that decision no you're gonna feel
much better about creating whatever you
wanted to create an SF Godin always
talks about you got to create bad stuff
first so so Xander if you're aspiring to
start a podcast just start it create
some bad ones and you don't even have to
publish them yet but if you what if you
were to create one podcast episode every
day for the next 30 days you think we
better 30 days from now
or today of course you'll be better 30
days from now because you've put in some
work you put in some practice Ryan and I
on episode 120 are much better at
podcasting than we were on episode
number one um I just I don't know why
this guy's is weird I don't know I'm
just looking at the and his Ed's Anders
question it's a little weird that he's
asking about social media and talking
about starting a podcast and I and the
reason why I'm saying it's weird is
because they have nothing to do with
each other
mmm meaning that one of the lessons I've
learned is that it doesn't matter social
media it does not matter yeah
creating a good podcast that's what
matters social media can help get the
word out more it can help you know
communicate with people answer questions
whatever it people can you know throw us
there their thoughts on the podcast and
their crappy reviews for the great
reviews whatever it is yeah
but at the end of the day put a quarter
in the jar for my at the end of the day
jar it does xander it doesn't matter
social media does not matter here's my
advice and err quit social media and
start a podcast that's that's the best
advice we could give you yeah I think so
and so so and then when you if you
decide to go back to social media let it
all meant whatever you've created right
let it magnify let it amplify what
you've created don't let it be the
creation of a cell oh here's what also
there are a few exceptions is that there
are some comedians I follow on Twitter
where it is their primary communication
platform it's their creation platform
there are Twitter comedians and they're
really funny and that is the best format
for them but for most things it is not
the primary means on which we we should
communicate in fact one of the things I
wrote down here that isn't in the essay
one of the things I learned during this
month off is Twitter is still my
favorite platform for me right and I
think part partly because I still use
that to create a little bit it's almost
like they're gonna break from writing I
can write these little pithy tweets in
fact if you go back and look at maybe my
last year of tweets you can track what
essays I was working on because you'll
see like these little these little
minimal Maxim's or quotes or whatever
you want to call them that make it to my
Twitter feed sometimes I'll make it into
an essay sometimes they won't but it
will
than provoke me enough to create the
thing that I want to create the I also
learned that from me again this is just
for me Instagram is generally a waste of
time and I mean that literally like when
I want to waste time that is the first
place I go it is a pacifier right and
we're gonna talk about pacifiers here in
a moment in the essay I also learned
that I don't use Facebook I don't miss
it at all the only reason I have a
Facebook account is because one of us
has to have one for two in order to
manage the minimalist dude Ryan does not
have a Facebook account oh I got a
question for you in go for I had a
question pop into my head so you're
talking about lessons you've learned
what is the what's the most useful thing
you have found on social media since
you've been back meaning like since
you've got back on Twitter or Facebook
Instagram you've already said is pretty
much a waste of time so the outlets that
do add value because I'm trying to think
for myself I can't think of one instance
where I've got back on social media and
I was like oh thank god I'm back on here
like I enjoy like we went and had dinner
at a restaurant were they it was an
amazing restaurant I told the guy hey
I'll be happy to share about your
restaurant if it's an amazing meal I
mentioned it on the on the podcast
yaksha's pocket yeah a couple weeks ago
um and I was really happy to get on
social media and like give sake Rock a
shout out because they did such an
awesome job
so for me again like that that's great
but but my life would be just as fine if
I did not mention that first right but
what you were doing with something
helpful and so salute what you're saying
there is social media adds value to your
life when it allows you to be more
helpful well I think it's well yeah that
is one of the ways for sure
yeah I guess it's the biggest way back
to that question of what what value has
social media added to you sure because
I'm asking that myself this question
since we got back on five days ago yeah
so so this morning I just talked about
that photo I posted of the bear that
yeah Eric made back in Dayton on
Instagram yeah and it allowed me to be
helpful right yeah so if I'm just
browsing Instagram it's a waste of time
but can instead of adding to that noise
it's gonna waste other people's sign how
can I be helpful in some way what
allowed me to talk about a handcrafted
product it allowed me to talk about how
it's not an advertisement it allowed me
to to shout out Eric who does such a
great job and he does these other things
he makes these bears with like old
Carhartt clothes and he repurposes
things in a way and makes them beautiful
and it's exactly in line with our ethos
and everything he makes is one of one
mm-hmm
and when it sells out when he sells the
one it sold out there isn't a duplicate
and so it's it's very much in line with
our values and so I can tell you the few
since hopping back on there been a few
things that have added value to my life
and it's not what I expected this I'm
glad you asked me that question one is
my favorite thing to do on so all social
media is just tweet whatever LSS yeah so
backs and I have a four-year-old at Ella
sandwich on Twitter and instead of
having a scrapbook at home or some sort
of collection of whatever about her
childhood we collect her her beautiful
nonsense and so she'll say something let
me pull up her account we'll look at the
most recent ones because they yeah so
while you're pulling it up like you've
taken Ella's hilarious quotes uh-huh it
basically it's it's you know what was
that Cosby Show those [ __ ] kids say or
dumb things kids have what was it called
yeah yeah yeah I forget what it was
called by Tom but anyway I was like you
know dumb things kids say I don't know I
don't know why I can't remember that but
what you've done is you've you've
basically made it better in my opinion
but because it's it's uh it's these nice
little tweetable one-liners you know
yeah yeah I'm not putting down that show
and I can't even remember what the show
was called but but yeah my point is is
that you've been able to take Ella's
funny sayings and create some very
entertaining things can the world live
without all the sayings of course man
but it sure is a better place with it I
think yeah to my life because I'm
constantly like actually in a weird way
it makes me pay closer attention to what
she's saying oh that's great so here a
few recently she said the whole world
not what I thought it was not everyone
gives me what I asked that's good she
said she looked at her mom she goes how
do you trick people and then asking the
important questions just yesterday she
said who's winning the slow eating
contest I'm winning and it's so true she
could totally win a slow eating contest
and so I find value in that I find value
in Twitter I follow a curated list of
people and and brands or businesses or
whatever you want to call them and
whenever I am feeling like it doesn't
align with what I want to take in I will
I will very liberally unfollow whomever
right all right that's a good point
maybe cuz I I am I have learned in
really still learning that I have to use
social media differently just in the
sense of like right now the way what I
get out of it when I go to my feed its
passive its wasting time yes I go to
social media when I'm bored and I I have
to change that we have to embrace the
board this sometimes and let's turn it
in before before then because being
bored isn't a bad thing being bored is
quite often yeah I was I was walking
through Runyon Canyon yesterday and had
my headphones in am I always take these
out and like let me be in the moment
like let me be bored in a way because
quite often that's when some of the most
profound thoughts and and ideas reach me
is in those moments of boredom and if
we're constantly stimulating ourselves
because it really what you're saying is
we're searching for stimuli right when
we're on the toilet scrolling through
instagrams like I need something to
stimulate me right now right now I need
this and in fact the the next point in
this essay is unfollow that's the the
fourth lesson learned here out of the
the five lessons learned whether it's
celebrities on Instagram friends on
Facebook or news outlets on Twitter
maybe we can say bad news outlets on
Twitter the folks we follow often
negatively affect our moods we get
caught up
comparing ourselves with others we get
dragged down by naysayers and we start
twitching for 24-hour quote breaking
news whenever this is the case it's best
to unfollow those negative influences
and instead curate a feed that includes
people and brands who inform us
challenge us and improve us letting go
of the negative is the only way to make
room for the valuable and I think that
last line is important we have to let go
of the the bad news the breaking news
the urge to stimulate in order to make
room for that which is truly valuable to
us and that's the fifth and final lesson
and then we get to the bad habits the
unlearn bad habits the final lesson here
is value as the minimalist will post the
social media only when it adds value to
others before we publish to any platform
we must be able to affirmatively answer
one question does this add value if not
then delete that's the thing that I'll
ask before I post something you know
it's like is this actually gonna add
value to our audience is it gonna serve
the greater good in some way and if not
be willing to delete it or at least save
it as a draft and say I said your wrath
let's save it as a draft yeah they've
got long necks and then they'll come
back to it later and say okay will this
add value you don't have to post right
now in fact that can be another lesson
learned here is before you post why not
save it for a day can't it wait 24 hours
there are some things they can't there
are some things where you're trying to
embark on a conversation and maybe it
makes more sense to post something now
but for the most part it can usually
wait a day and a day later if you're
like what was I thinking and just delete
it it's okay yeah there's some funny the
the thinking of thinking about the not
acting on the impulse and tweeting
something into the next part where we're
getting to the idiots home it makes me
think about when someone they will yeah
you know whatever they're tweeting at me
um Ryan your face sucks and then like
I'll go to their Twitter feed oh and
I'll retweet that yeah Josh after Josh
retweets it
I go to their Twitter feed and a lot of
the times they're just like visceral
comment after visceral comma
towards random people yeah and I you
know what I'm security man yeah it's
like their whole string of of tweets are
just this real comments to different
people that they want to be mean to for
whatever reason yeah and and we it's
easy you know the to tear other people's
buildings down to try to make us that
look taller so to speak yeah but man how
unproductive is that yeah so pitted me
of being on production so for all of
those folks out there I have been that
person before I have definitely trolled
I'm certain that 24 25 years old I did
some stupid stuff in chat rooms on
MySpace and MySpace yes but I guess the
reason why I bring that up is instead of
just going out and troll and just sit on
up for 24 hours and really consider if
that's actually gonna make a difference
or not yeah yeah you know I signed up
for Twitter Facebook in myspace all on
the same day and I know I was late to
the game I can't believe I'm still in
your top five you top eight man oh it's
you and Tom hurt my feelings
Griffen house them in the table eh
anyway we've got some unlearned bad
habits here the first unlearned bad
habit is called idiots if the purpose of
social media is to communicate with
other humans then we also must be
careful with whom we engage people find
it easy to be keyboard Crusaders that's
what we the person you're just talking
about they're interacting with
interactions with whom are rarely
productive so it's important not to
engage with the snarky critics because
this isn't for them and I have a whole
link in that essay to another essay
talking about this probably isn't for
you
right hence if you're a seagull of
another essay they're called seagulls
well it was seagulls do they they
swooped in they [ __ ] all over you and
they fly away right that's what we call
the internet trolls really they're
seagulls hints if you're a seagull
you'll be blocked without discrimination
and you won't be unblocked ever we have
a renewed desire to communicate with our
audience and a new vigor to avoid
arguing with idiots oh oh man I used to
argue with idiots on oh yeah and it's so
unproductive we all get caught up I
could be creating and
you're keeping me from creating here's
another rule that I don't have in the
essay here but I don't respond to people
I mean I use social media to respond to
people especially Twitter but I won't
respond to you if you ask a question
that's easily searchable right hey have
you guys ever written about you when you
quit your jobs mmm no I'm not gonna
respond to that yeah you could just
search minimalist quitter jobs yeah yeah
um I was gonna I was gonna say I was
talking about an about the idiots on the
internet and she had she had brought up
this story about this someone
influential who had big following
they're doing a live stream this one
particular person was going out of their
way trolling the heck out of this person
she took the time to be like what is
what is your problem dude
like what is actually going on and then
actually turns out there's this amazing
like heartfelt story where this guy was
on the verge of suicide and like she
turned him around basically like really
went out of her way to like help him get
the help he deserved so my aunt she's
telling me this story and she was like
you know I understand that you know you
get trolls every once in a while but
maybe you could you know take take that
approach more and I'm like I'm like
Michelle I love you and this is a great
idea and I do this to a certain extent
meaning if someone asks a legitimate
question or they have like a legitimate
hey I'm I'm having trouble finding you
know finding the finding a way to
understand how you know you guys are
doing X but you know but but I'm
thinking why you know insert argument
there to me that is a very that's
something that I am gonna look at and
say how can i how can I help you better
understand how can I communicate yeah
and thanks for reaching out but when
someone just is is visceral to me if I
did if I took the time with every single
person I would not have time to do what
we are already doing to like you said to
create to help more than just you know
filtering out for that through that one
person so it's it's not that you know
Josh and I it's not that we don't have
sympathy and understand that some of
these people we do know where they're
coming from but but really what it comes
down to is yeah dude like there's no way
we're going to let someone not just take
the wind out of our sails but but you
hit the nail on the head dude like just
preventing us from creating every single
minute every single five minutes or an
hour that we ruminate or try to rebuttal
a troll that is that is less time that
we have to create something that could
potentially help many many more people I
mean how many times do people come up to
us at you know in the Huglin and they're
like man you guys don't even know this
but like you saved my life like that's
what I'm focused on yeah yeah and and we
can't I can't make someone like me and
I'm not going to trial right and but you
just got to be you and this time I was
so caught up in that way but no I'm
right and I'm gonna prove you wrong I
want you to see it from my perspective
Rob Bell says something this week in his
podcast he said you can be right in the
wrong way yeah and and that that's what
I was learning is like yeah I'm right
but I'm approaching this the wrong way
the right way for me to approach this
thing is just to move on and help the
people who I can't help and ignore the
idiots and yeah so we block very
liberally if you are a troll you get
blocked with the quickness and now we
won't unblock you either
it's what crystally uh one of our
favorite comedians he just tells people
welcome to my block party welcome to my
block by block so I saw there was a
tweet he put out recently to put a
screenshot of no yeah he put a
screenshot of someone who said why did
you block me on Instagram and Chris
Vaughn he goes probably because you were
being an [ __ ] and now I'm gonna block
you on Twitter too that's great and I
kind of feel the same way
block the the seagull so you can move on
and that goes for any of you if you if
you're out there and and it doesn't I do
follow people who challenge me and
challenge my ideas that's different from
these from these seagulls the next
unlearned
habit is pacifiers hmm by removing the
social media apps from our phones which
often pacified us whenever we had a
silent moment in an airport waiting room
or other interstitial zone like a
bathroom sitting on the toilet scrolling
scrolling through Instagram there once
removed the ass from our phones we
learned that new pacifiers always appear
if you get rid of Facebook you twitch
for Twitter if Instagram is gone
YouTube steps in 2000 years ago the
Stoics complained about people getting
lost in books instead of going out and
experiencing the real world today we
complain that nobody reads books anymore
because everyone is lost in the tempting
glow of their screens whether it's books
or social media we get lost in we must
work hard to use these tools
deliberately to help us function in the
real world not remove ourselves from it
and for me this is this is where I sort
of depart a little bit from people you
might call a Luddite I certainly
wouldn't call him that but Cal Newport
so so Cal Newport runs a great blog
called study hacks he he's very talented
all three wrote deep work and he is
working on book now called digital
minimalism and he and I've been just
talking about the different approaches
now he has a TED talk out there called
quit social media I will put a link to
that in the show notes it's out there
and he encourages people to quit social
media and if you he's never had a social
media platform ever and if you disagree
with him he encouraged you to message
him on Twitter and it I just I'm just
gonna let it hang there yeah he's a
hashtag because he doesn't have a handle
but if he believes in deep work and it
requires not being on social media he
thinks the the cons outweigh the pros of
social media I disagree because I want
to live in a world that we can use
social media deliberately now is that
possible I think so I'm not entirely
certain though and that's why we're back
on and by the way all of this is subject
to change if next month or next week or
next year we just say hey
we're no longer finding value in X
platform then we we walk away from X
platform that's okay or hey man you know
what that twitch platform looks really
really cool we're gonna start doing
twitch streaming right because it makes
sense for us or tumblr or whatever
Google+ and so yes we will pacify
ourselves and it's always been a problem
though the Stoics said the books
yeah books are the problem because
everyone's just stuck on that that page
and then out in the real world and now
we're not out in the real world or we're
not reading books because we're stuck in
the glowing the glowing screens that are
in our hands and what I'm hearing you
say is that no matter what point in time
of human history there is technology
that gets introduced that becomes a
pacifier yeah and that takes a human
interaction away
do you trust on Harrison he used to be
an ethicist for google when he walked
away and he started this this nonprofit
called time well-spent but then he also
started this this second nonprofit
called the Center for Humane Technology
and he sort of writes about how what
you're just saying is absolutely true
where there was this new technology that
distracted us right and there have been
new distractions all on the way but he
posits that this new distraction of
technology is different from all the
previous oh absolutely action absolutely
I think what I was trying to get at is
that this is part of human existence man
yeah it is learning how to it is
learning how to fight the impulses to
pacify ourselves and social media is a
great pacifier exactly and and and so
it's a new pacifier maybe we haven't
developed the mechanisms to deal with it
yet to keep from pacifying ourselves to
death I mean I think back to David
Foster Wallace's book and I jest is
about entertaining ourselves to death
the sort of MacGuffin of that novel is
it is this movie that is fatally
entertaining like as soon as you put the
cartridge into the whatever the the TV
player is because took play I mean it
was written in the early 90s but it took
place I think at 2017 this distant
future
and and when you played this movie
called Infinite Jest you entertained
yourself to death because you wanted to
do nothing else but sit there and
continue to watch this movie on repeat
you wouldn't need you wouldn't go to the
bathroom you just sit there and you go
to the bathroom alright right you
wouldn't get up to go to the bathroom
yeah and because it was so entertaining
and you base a diet it was like the
heroine of entertainment exactly and and
so now in a weird way it feels like
that's becoming true because you see
these kids who are putting these diapers
on while they're playing these these
video games for 40 hours straight and
ordering pizza and and and in a
meaningful way they're dying mmm and
sometimes they're literally dying but
but in a meaningful way that they are
pacifying themselves to death and we're
doing that to a lesser extent with with
some of these social media outlets so
yeah well oh one other thing I thought
about here Ryan is as we were talking
about this pacification joe rogan has
this great analogy he's like what if I
told you there was a drug out there that
made you get in the car crashes you felt
constantly distracted by it you were it
interrupted your conversations with
friends and you were constantly looking
down at your hand moving your thumb in
this weird up-and-down motion if there
was a drug that did that to you the
government would probably ban it except
now it's just our smartphones we're all
I mean you go somewhere I notice it all
the time I notice myself doing it too so
I'm not I'm not exempt from this if I'm
standing in line somewhere everyone is
just staring down at the screen because
I need that stimuli I need that pacifier
right now right but if if Ryan if I saw
you doing that without your phone I
would try to get you help
yeah you'd there'd be something wrong
with me yeah and and I would blame me
I'm really concerned about Ryan like
he's just doing this with his thumb all
day he's staring down at his hand have
you seen the artwork that of where the
the the artists photo shops the phones
out of the people's hands oh yes yeah
yeah and so all of a sudden they're just
all sitting there at a table like a
dinner table together all staring down
at their hands
and man it's terrifying to think how
we're how we're using some of the the
things that we're supposed to be useful
right the next the next lesson that is
unlearned to the bad habit unlearned
rather is promos with this one's called
Pro molas there's too much branding
going on these days no there aren't any
advertisements on our web site or a
podcast or social media feeds but even
we the minimalists have been guilty of
too much self-promotion getting in the
way of our own creations
perhaps Derek Siver's said it best
putting ads in your work is like putting
a Coke machine in a monastery and we
feel the same way about all the
shameless self-promotion that's going on
these days including our own it's
solipsistic we're pledging to remove the
Coke machine from the monastery
immediately so you can better enjoy what
we're creating and sharing without all
the promotional eyesores yes we'll
occasionally talk about what we're
working on including events books and
projects but we won't let it get in the
way of what we're creating if anything
promotion should be similar to the in
credits of a film not the main plot so
you'll notice that even with our podcast
like one thing we try to do now is we
don't beat you over the head up front of
the podcast like hey here's what we're
working on come out to our tour stops we
know that people the people who listen
all the way through are the the what
Kevin Kelly would call one of the
thousand true fans those are the people
are gonna want to attend our events
anyway so later in the podcast I'll talk
about how we're coming to Australia or
if we have another event or something
well we'll talk about that later on but
we don't have to you know start off the
podcast but when I listen to some of my
favorite podcast they have 10 minutes of
advertisements at the very beginning
that's the Coke machine in the monastery
yeah and it is really nice though that
that you know fast for 30-second button
that's really nice though yeah I agree
and and I get that you know the
advertisements help keep the lights on
and of course it's not me judging other
people for that I was who was Upton
Sinclair who said it is difficult to get
a man to understand something when his
salary depends on his not understanding
it amen
and so how can I tell how could I
possibly go to NBC and say you shouldn't
do advertisement separate that that's
part of what
is destroying our our culture or our
mind or you can't go to Facebook and
tell them that they need to change their
algorithm to make it less addictive
because it is difficult to get a man or
a brand to understand something when his
salary depends on not understanding it
and I think that that quote is the best
way to summarize why we don't do
advertisements yeah alright the the next
the next unlearned bad habit here is
triplicate over the years we began using
the different social media platforms the
exact same way which when you think
about it is insane right I mean you know
dude every time I went to our essays and
I'm like okay posted on fate or essays
or a podcast posted on Facebook posted
on Twitter posted on Google+ posted on
Pinterest
yeah on all my personal accounts it was
like it felt like such a just felt a
little weird
but anyway yeah and I totally agree it
was a digital version of those old
carbon copy forms from decades past post
a photo to Instagram repost as a Twitter
and then re repost it to Facebook lather
rinse repeat
triplicate in our efforts isn't only
tedious it's the opposite of using these
platforms intentional and that is
shotgunning yeah we as some people use
this platform so I'm gonna go and throw
it on there right and so what what we
want to do instead is use them for what
we find to be the best purpose and so
the next session a section in this essay
is using social media differently
because each social media platform is
different we want to use them
differently not as a carbon copy so
we've decided to focus on the specific
strengths of each platform by
identifying their primary and secondary
uses these changes should help us avoid
creative overlap and will allow us to
better communicate with our audience so
Facebook here's how we're using Facebook
going forward and again keep in mind
this is all subject to change we're
testing it at testing the waters to see
if this is in fact the best way for us
to use it and also this isn't a
prescription for you it's just a
template for us absolutely so Facebook
we found our Facebook audience engages
most with the articles we post the
we'll be using our Facebook account
primarily to share useful links be it
our own essays or others simple living
articles secondarily we'll use Facebook
to publish short audiograms and photo
albums from past tours so if we have a
bunch of photos from a tour that we went
on we can collect it all there on
Facebook you have a nice photo album
there on Facebook and then audiograms
it's a uh diagram is a short sort of
snippet from our podcast and there's a
link there you can take a look so
sometimes Ryan and I will somehow manage
to say something pithy or entertaining
and Jessica will collect that and use
the program called audiogram to share
sort of a one or two minute snippet of
of something we said during a podcast
alright the next one is is Twitter so
Twitter is the best platform for us to
share text only minimal maxims so we're
gonna use if we're using Facebook for
links whether it's our own links or
other people's link so we're sharing
these useful articles we found that our
Facebook audience engages the most with
those they get the most value from those
Twitter is the best platform for us to
share our text only so we're not gonna
share any links we're not gonna share
any photos on Twitter we're just gonna
share the text and I'm also occasional
retweet stuff from people that may or
may not contain a a link and secondarily
we'll use Twitter to communicate
directly with our audience the brevity
of Twitter makes it the best place for
us to interact with other people so if
you want to interact with us directly
Twitter is by far the best place to do
so I I find it so much more complicated
to try to interact on Facebook or on
Instagram we may do so occasionally but
if you really want to interact with us
we're at the minimalists on Twitter I
mean we're at the minimalists on all the
platforms but Twitter is the best place
to interact with us as far as Instagram
is concerned Instagram is undoubtedly
the best platform to share photos right
it's the photo platform so going forward
we'll use Instagram primarily to share
beautiful black and white images
secondarily will use the ephemerality of
Instagram stories to brought that's sort
of like for those who are unfamiliar
with it it's kind of like snapchats
these these these moments that disappear
15-second moments or a photo that
disappear after 24 hours so we use the
ephemerality
of Instagram stories to broadcast
updates current events and ephemera and
also useful excerpts from our blog posts
and podcast so little bite-sized
snippets that we'll share on Instagram
which will be different from the other
platforms and will occasionally use
Instagram live for unplanned live
broadcasts which are deleted after 24
hours I really like that because you do
it and then they're gone you can
interact with your audience but it
doesn't live out there and the
Internet's ether forever and then a
Pinterest is the next one Pinterest is
the Internet's cork board and I wrote
this down because I didn't put this in
the essay Ryan but for me I found the
Pinterest again for me
I said Twitter was my favorite and
Instagram is a waste of time and I don't
use Facebook Pinterest can be a black
hole I very rarely go there but it's
easy to sort of get lost in it cuz I
will I will find this image and I sort
of go down this this black hole it
doesn't it is for everyone I also
understand some people find more value
in pinterest than anywhere else so it is
the internet's corkboard so it's ideal
for us to share our letter boards which
Jessica creates and makes really
beautiful
these letter boards contain challenges
and simple living reminders from the
minimalist will also use our Pinterest
account to repost photos of minimalist
living spaces or our director Matt D
Avella he just he just posted a tour of
his minimalist home and he goes with his
not so minimalist girlfriend and we
shared that over on Pinterest so you
could see some photos you can click
through actually and see a video of his
minimalist home it's a short two minute
tour of of his home speaking of videos
YouTube that's the the last platform
that we use since YouTube is the premier
video platform this is where we publish
videos created by the minimalist this
will be especially relevant when we add
a video version of our podcast later
this year so if you're interested in
that you know just go to youtube.com
slash the minimalist eventually we'll
have a video version of this podcast
when we have enough patreon supporters
to afford all the gear that's associated
with that secondarily we'll use YouTube
to post other video creations video
essays web series and scheduled live
streams it's the best place for that
you'll notice our absence from most
social media platforms snapchat LinkedIn
Tumblr ello Google+
periscope Flickr reddit Cora etc that's
not because these services aren't useful
they simply aren't useful for us right
now so this thing you were talking about
earlier Ryan yeah one day we might say
it which is a great platform for us to
livestream let's go over to that I
didn't even mention that in this
paragraph but well case to me it's like
it's such a it's such a relevant
platform like it's a it's a very
relevant platform it is and but it is so
irrelevant for you and I that's why I
brought up specific and I think snapchat
is the same way so that shadows is
relevant and the whole point here is
that yeah there's one you're always
gonna miss it on something there is it
definitely even if you're on every
social media network we have mentioned
so far there's some out there that
you're just not on mm-hmm and it's okay
it's fun and if you're looking so for
Xander if if you're looking or anyone
else who is if you're looking to augment
your creations with a social media
platform find the one you get the most
value in and start with that for us we
started with Twitter and then we added
on over the last seven years and then
don't use them all the same if you can
avoid it right and that's really what
this strategy for us is about is not
using them all the same let's use them
differently let's use them for their
strengths and see what happens when we
do that yeah
All Things Considered we hope to use our
new strategy to creatively add value to
other people's lives this is our recipe
and it isn't ideal for everyone truth be
told it might not even be ideal for
anyone but us and even then we'll likely
adjust how we wield these tools after
using them differently for a while no we
don't expect you to follow us in every
platform hell we don't expect you to
follow us on any platform but if you
find value in what we're communicating
feel free to join us on our new journey
and if you ever stop finding value in
what we're sharing
please unfollow us at any time all right
so that's that's that essay I don't know
if there's anything else to to tweeze
out here for well here's what I'll say
presenting like just the kind of answer
is his question questions head-on he's
got to have a plan like I'm literally
sitting here like you know following
along with you as you're reading this
essay we put out into why didn't we do
this from the beginning yeah
like why the hell did we not come up
with a plan like this in the beginning
so Xander won from our mistake man and
come up with a plan how do you come up
with that plan like you've got to ask
yourself what are you trying to
accomplish what are you trying to
communicate with each of these platforms
it sounds to me Xander like the podcast
is the one that you should start with
and like I said earlier dude quit social
media and start your podcast like that
is what is going to matter the content
ooh I said it Josh I'm taking it back
just a dollar bill and the doors see
whatever I can you never mind Xander has
to create something and getting on
social media and in trying to figure out
how to be relevant on social media is
going to really stifle his creation
I agree and so the creation that you're
working on will not be meaningful at
first probably Plus so don't worry about
social medias and or just worry about
creating but the act of creating in and
of itself is meaningful amen
and as you go further down the road you
will actually start to create something
that is meaningful you know what I wrote
for the better part of a decade before I
published anything at all now I'm not
recommending that for everyone I
probably should have started publishing
something a bit sooner especially I
didn't have all the tools that are out
there now whether it's blogging or
self-publishing or all these are the
tools that are out there for people you
you don't have to wait for someone
else's permission
Suzanne Durr you don't need our
permission to start your podcast you
just need to you just need to start it I
think about something that Derek Siver's
wrote he has a book that he's rewriting
right now called the mindset of
marketing your music and he in there he
talks about how his time is worth you
know how much is your time worth Xander
let's say it's worth 50 dollars an hour
you're a young person in fact I would
argue as a young person your time is
probably worth a lot more than that I
heard Jordan Peterson talking about this
recently because it compounds right and
so if you learn or create something
today if Xander on how old you are but
let's say you're 20 for the sake of this
this argument
something that you learned today
an hour of your time compounds over the
next decades and it's actually worth a
lot more because every hour that you
spend working on something meaningful
you're gonna have that now as an asset
the the skill that you develop becomes
an asset for you right and so Derek
Siver's like you know he said I I assume
my time was probably worth $500 an hour
not literally like I don't think I'm
good a job for $5.00 hour but that's how
much I put on on on that time and so I'm
is it worth it to spend an hour
scrolling through Instagram and a day if
you go to the moment app and if you have
that moment app you can track the
activity on your phone so definitely
something I recommend the folks who are
struggling with all this you just get
the moment app on your phone and if you
look and say oh man I was on Instagram
for an hour a day would you have given
$500 to be on Instagram today
well of course or maybe your times only
worth 50 bucks an hour or $25 an hour
would you pay 25 bucks to be on
Instagram for an hour I know I wouldn't
and so when we think about it that way
we sort of we flip the table over and
realize like wait a minute is this worth
my time and often the answer is no the
last thing that he asked about here Ryan
is how can people use social media less
but make it better
and I think the answer to that question
is actually in the question right
absolutely use it less but make it
better
and that's what this whole strategy was
about for us we want to use it less
we're actually gonna be posting loss
we're only posting like one thing a day
on on Instagram you know that's not a
rule that we made but that's actually a
good rule that I mean people could make
yeah it's like if you if you are so how
to create to put rules around it because
that's I think what people a lot of
folks reach out to us they want they
wanna they want a rule or an ingredient
yeah a definitive way to do it yeah that
they can look at and they could say oh
yeah that makes sense or they can look
at it and say no these guys are nuts but
if they want to put a rule behind it or
if they don't want to put a robe on it
to create meaningful creations with less
use then yeah then challenge yourself to
use only one platform and post once a
day or once a week like because why cuz
limitations breed creativity absolutely
and and so I was actually it's funny you
mentioned that Ryan because I didn't put
this in the essay intentionally because
I think I might change drastically
but I was talking to Jessica on the
phone last weekend about this and I was
telling her you know what like I think
we need to put some guidelines these
aren't rules but some initial guidelines
about how we post and so let's just post
one photo a day on Instagram just to see
what that looks like she's like well I
don't know because what if we need to do
that I'm like yeah what if we need to do
it we're gonna have to decide we're
gonna have to choose which is gonna add
more value to our audience right and so
that limitation is going to breed
some-some creativity and then with
Twitter like don't post more than three
things a day on Twitter excluding maybe
commenting to other people but original
tweets from us the text only minimal
Maxim's and fewer than then three a day
three or fewer a day and then on what's
the other one Facebook write one or two
links a day and that is it create some
boundaries for yourself yeah create
those boundaries and then know if you
have to step past them there better be a
really good reason your stuff and past
them and and you might feel this twinge
of slight pain when you do step past
them and that's that maybe that's not a
bad thing after all all right Xander I'd
love to send you a copy of our book
minimalism live a meaningful life it's
the first book Ryan and I wrote about
the the five values there are
foundational values that Ryan and I have
built our lives on but one of those is
passion or creativity and and and when
you're looking at creating something new
it is something you want to develop into
a passion it's not follow your passion
its cultivate a passion and we talked
about how to do that it's in the third
chapter of that book it's called
minimalism living meaningful life
Charlie can send him the audio book or
if he wants the physical book instead or
even the e-book if you reach out to
Xander in Orlando and get that over to
him all right we have a question from
Michelle and Edmonton I have an idea for
a home business and up until now I've
given my products to just like as gifts
to friends and family and they all love
them they're very supportive of my
business endeavor but what I'm really
struggling with is how to create a
social media strategy for my business
without compromising my personal privacy
I feel like minimalism has really helped
me to balance my personal needs with the
demands of reality with work with
relationships
and I haven't had a social media profile
in over four years which has allowed me
to really cherish my personal privacy
and I just feel overwhelmed by the
demands associated with managing on
social media account hold on is she
asking for advice on a plan for social
media or she asking how to stay
anonymous I think she's asking how to
protect her privacy okay and and the
interesting word that she used there and
I don't know how intentional this was
but it really stood out to me is demands
like the demands this puts on me and
there's a book there's a line from our
book everything that remains we're but
dogs thrashing the colors of our own
obligations and and and maybe you could
switch that word obligations with
demands our self-imposed demands and and
we've created this dog collar that keeps
us at tied to this post so to speak
because we're creating these own demands
and so so the first thing is don't don't
create the demand if if you can avoid it
and so she's talking about she made a
very sweeping statement my business
needs social media to thrive are there
any businesses that don't have social
media that thrive so yeah so that's a
great question Michele another great
question is why does my business need
social media to thrive you know there's
probably there might be a very valid
answer there that's not one I'm not
saying that that what she's saying isn't
true but you know how you and I are men
like we're always trying to get behind
the why because that's what really helps
us to make a better decision so she's
asking for the how and what we need to
first get get to is the why before we
can get to the how why do you need
social media have you even asked that
question is it because everyone else has
social media and if so that's probably
not the the best answer everyone else
has email right I'm thinking of this
article that Cal Newport wrote called
the wood worker who quit email this is a
guy in Kentucky we'll put a link to this
I'm not gonna read the whole thing but
basically he decided that like he was
spending too much of his time because he
he makes these creations he's a
woodworker he makes a product right but
he realized that at some point he was
responding to
customers potential requests and and he
was spending several hours a day not
creating because he was responding to
email and so he quit email mm-hmm
professionally he still had a personal
email but he said he had people like
they would work around it
send him something to his personal email
he just deletes it he has this steadfast
rule he says if a customer wants to get
a hold of me they can come to my shop in
Kentucky and they can ask me their
questions otherwise I'm just going to
keep creating and so it's a great it's a
great article called the woodworker who
quit email and and so he was asking that
question to why do I need email he
didn't he wouldn't even step farther
from social media right and in fact I
think one of the questions will answer
during the the lightning round
we'll end up talking about why even
return the social media at all and I
think it's a question that's worth
asking but form so for Michelle like
what yeah how does she keep her privacy
well I so it really depends on what you
mean by by privacy now Ryan you use the
word anonymous well she did say didn't
she say the word anonymous in her
question I don't know I didn't write
that down I put any but anyway she may
have but but if she if she didn't if she
wants to be anonymous then you can still
do that something that can be easier
than putting yourself out there sort of
a public figure like Ryan and I have
well I mean you can look at me
personally I don't have a personal
Facebook account but I have a but we
have the minimalist so my company is
represented online but yeah my I am able
to keep all of my my person my personal
life my all of my personal life
activities off of Facebook but you also
choose what what to share and so the
source there's an essay from our book
essential I'm going to send a copy of
this to to Michelle there's 12 chapters
in this book essential and so Sean if
you get sent her the audiobook but
there's this essay that is in the text
chapter there's an entire chapter on
technology and it's called online
congruence and I'll read a little
snippet from that because I think it'll
it'll spawn a bit of a conversation
between you and I Ryan I'm sitting in a
diner in Birmingham Alabama smelling the
ground coffee beans waiting through the
air sifting through emails from friends
one in particular stands out a close
friend is amid a tedious med school
application process and she's worried
about her Facebook account being used
against her by the folks who review
applications so in a weird way that this
is sort of what Michelle was talking
about used against her and a looser
sense like is fo shizzle if that's what
Michelle is saying then we need to have
an entirely different conversation with
Michelle I think so and that's the
conversation I want to start here so now
I don't even have an undergraduate an
undergraduate degree so I'm likely an
unfit advisor on grad school matters but
then again I don't really see this as a
collegiate affair at all rather it's a
matter of congruence and so really what
I wanna talk to Michelle today about his
congruence for the longest time I myself
led two separate lives there was
professional jfm and personal jfm there
was corporate me prim and proper all
sensibly flawless and then there was
creative me flawed but beautiful
beautiful because of the fault flaws
perhaps for obvious reasons the two
mixed about as well as glass rubbing
against concrete so I kept them
segregated corporate me didn't talk
about his love for writing and creative
me loathe hiding himself from the world
it was almost as though both sides were
ashamed of each other and so if if
that's what we're talking about if we're
talking about shame about who you are as
a person
then man that's that's what I felt in my
late 20s especially I had this creative
side that really wanted to get out in
the world I had this professional side
that had to hide my creative side so
there so if and I'm not saying this is
where Michelle is coming from no but if
what she is saying is I want to I want
to keep private because I don't want
people to know about my personal life I
just want them to know about my product
and if and again I'm not saying this is
where she's coming from but if her
thought is I don't want people knowing
about my personal life because I don't
want that that that's going to affect
how they view my product so then the
question Michelle needs ask herself is
would I be
willing to buy this product from a
person like me the the person who is
going to a an interview and they're
worried about you know Facebook the
question they need to be asking is if I
was this hiring manager what I hire
myself right now the example you gave
with that story
the answer is no mm-hmm that's it
completely that's a completely different
issue that that person needs to address
right right I think so and so so think
think about my my life though over time
this is from the essay here it took its
toll we're having the two separate
identities until eventually I realized
living two separate lives was exhausting
even disingenuous of me right it was
disingenuous to be this one guy
nine-to-five are really 9:00 to 9:00 or
whatever 7:00 a.m. to 10:00 p.m. I was
corporate jfm and it was exhausting and
disingenuous so instead of hiding one
half from the other half I decided to
change my activity to align both halves
and so for me it's it's not just about
privacy it's about having this sense of
online congruence is my personal and
professional self the same human being
right and so in my friends case she
wanted to go as far as changing her name
on social media my advice do you do
anything online you're not proud of in
real life if so I wouldn't change my
name I'd change my online activity
exactly so if you're doing something
that your unproductivity is more
important than trying to hide the
activity right well yeah it's funny cos
like I want to go deeper with this and
say the activities that those people are
doing they're doing them for a reason
right and you know might be because
they're trying to impress a certain
group of people but yet they have to
hide this activity so they can get hired
by a different group of people I mean
that whoever this person is in this
example like really needs to question
who are they trying to please yeah like
who what group of people are they trying
to be part of but yeah dude to your
point
they're trying to keep both groups
separate not knowing about each other
leave can come to completely different
lives it's possible yeah but dude that's
a miserable life yeah it is it's
exhausting if it's an exhausting life
and and and there's certain there's
gonna be always be this misery of this
discontent you're going to feel because
you're not gonna feel like yourself
because you're never you're full not
yourself yeah you're in congruent in a
way and again that's why I put myself in
the scenario that's it that was me for
sure and I can still see it now if
there's something I I'm afraid of
sharing or whatever I have to I have to
question like is this my best self so
for me there isn't an online self in a
real life self these days just myself
whether I write something online speak
to a crowd of people or have a
one-on-one conversation with a friend my
life is congruent don't get me wrong I
still have a private life and so this is
the part that really applies to Michele
here I still have a private life like
most people I enjoy having sex sending
dirty text messages and walking around
the house naked I just don't share those
details publicly not because I'm ashamed
because they're private and because they
don't contribute to the greater good
there's a big difference between a
public online profile which is an
extension of oneself and a private
intimate conversation personal
interactions that are not meant for
public consumption and so really
deciding what's private and what's
public that's a personal matter for you
Michele you can share whatever you like
just don't be ashamed of who you are
because shame is ugly right and so what
what we want to do when we're separating
our our public life and private life I
ask myself does this serve the greater
good and if so then I'm willing to share
it you know you're not gonna see a nude
selfie of me
that certainly would serve no I'm just
like rolling my lid I had my eyes right
now of like all the I'll come across
some Instagram celebrity picture gallery
like all these bathroom selfies or
something like and it's like hey
bathroom selfie picture gallery like
just people thinking
oh this is it's cute and funny because
I'm on the toilet and I'm gonna take a
picture of myself in the bathroom it's
like that is the that is like the I
don't know I don't know the only way to
get more masturbatory than that is by
putting a picture of yourself
masturbating on social media that's the
only way you could get more masturbatory
in my opinion yeah yeah I mean yeah it's
the epitome of that and so so I think
Michelle what I would encourage here is
is finding a line finding a boundary
between your private life and then ask
yourself as we stated early on why am I
using this and and I think there are
really two reasons to use social media
effectively there may be more but the
two that I see is to broadcast that
could be about your product or service
but you want to do so in a way that adds
value right you want to start a
conversation and that leads to the
second the second side of things it's
about communication right you're
communicating with an audience or a
potential audience about your product
what you don't want to do is just get
out there and be like look at my Prada
look at this look at this look at this
or even if you're not doing it from your
own point of view your company's one of
you look at our new product it's great
it's beautiful no why do people care why
do people want to follow that how are
you adding value another person I would
encourage you to follow on social media
he's on Facebook and Twitter scott
stratten
and he he has a great podcast called
unmarked attacks about how do we
communicate our products and services
with the world in a genuine way how can
we be congruent with what we're trying
to to broadcast to the world and then
for you Michele decide what's off-limits
for you and then draw the line there and
the line may change over time over time
you may be more comfortable sharing more
about yourself or you may become less
comfortable and in fact I think for me
I've become more and more private online
over the past few years because I was
oversharing at one point and I'd rather
I'd rather take that time to to create
right just read this article the other
day about how it was a study done on
people who constantly post pictures of
them
their significant other yeah and how the
more pictures you see online of that
person in their significant other there
is a correlation with the more insecure
the the worse the relationship is
inverse relationship like there's
between the way it looks online and the
way it is in real life exactly and it's
funny because I was so happy myself this
cuz Mariah I she's like you know um you
don't post enough pictures of me online
she's never actually said that verbatim
but like you know every once in a while
she will mention something like um yeah
you know maybe you could put more
pictures on me on there or whatever it
is man like some you know she sees other
people posting pictures of their
relations every other picture and she
wants people to know that her and I have
an amazing relationship so she wants to
me and it to project the same thing
which I totally understand but when I
found this article I sent it to her and
I'm like this is a very good sign that I
don't do this by the way yeah yeah yeah
definitely I mean and obviously it's a
it's correlation it's not causation base
there's our great relationships out
there they post every single picture
that they've ever taken sure there are
terrible relationships that don't post
any pictures maybe because they're
ashamed right and so the last thing I
will tell Michelle here is this question
that you're asking
it's the question I started wrestling
with in 2014 and I it's taken you know 3
plus years of December 2014 after we
finished that big tour I remember
sitting down and saying we're using
social media in a way that's in
triplicate and it's not that useful but
here's the sad thing I didn't have the
courage to to make the change sooner
right to sit down with you Ryan
and then eventually Jessica or whomever
and and and say hey we need to do a
better job of curating this of adding
value using these tools as tools and not
you have you have a hammer I want to use
it as a hammer and I want to beat
someone over the head with it right
we weren't beating people over the head
with it we just weren't using it to our
full potential we were doing a good job
at social me we were shotgunning dude
but we weren't doing a great job no we
were shotgunning yeah and so that's
that's done we're done doing that it's
not about promoting us it's not about
it's it's about adding value to an
audience and if we can do that and
use it to communicate products and
services that we may occasionally put
out there great that's not the primary
driver and certainly making money from
it it's not a primary driver you know
you'll never see an advertisement in
there or anything like that we want to
use it to augment our creations and so
Michelle if you can do that I think
you'd be off to a really good start
all right sure we'd love to hear what
you have to say about social media so if
you have a comment or tip about social
media including advice for any of our
callers today or if movie you just want
to talk about the Martin Luther King
videos and tell us why we're wrong or
why we're right then leave us a
voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine it's my favorite
portion of the show at the end of each
show we air our favorite comments and
tips from our listeners if you don't
want to leave us a voicemail you can
send a voicemail right from your phone
to podcast at the minimalists comm and
will air our favorite and comments and
tips on the next episode Ryan what time
is it it is time for me to go back to
the previous question no I just want to
add one more thing for Michelle man
before we move on to the lightning round
Michelle you have the opportunity now to
set the expectations I was just thinking
of this when you were reading the the
little interest of the lightning round
yeah and I just got to get this out like
Michelle you have the opportunity to set
the expectations now and to manage
expectations it's not just like for your
friends and family with how you're gonna
be on social media but with your
customer base this is so important so I
wish Josh and I had done a better job of
managing that expectation when we first
started and we're doing a great job now
and it's it's totally fixable in
something we've been able to you know as
you seen this this episode kind of
correct but yeah learn from our mistakes
Michelle and like we told Xander have a
plan and with that plan yeah you can set
you can set good expectations all right
well and learn from your own mistakes
too right you'll make some mistakes
along the way and we're going to to
adjust accordingly all right all right
we can move on to our landing round
sorry let's do it
all right then oh yeah we have to say
something about the lightning round
do we know we don't it's not for a
lightning round so we're on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram at the minimalist
erna lighting around this where Ryan and
I do our best to each answer each
question with just a short shareable
less than hundred forty character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our put the answers
on social media if you'd like and
can now find all our quotes in one place
minimal Maxim's calm alright alright our
first lightning round question is from
ELISA ELISA wants to know how do you
determine the line between too much and
just enough for people who still need to
promote stuff did being off social media
reveal any lack of value or value for
getting the word out about projects yes
here's my short answer if it feels like
too much it's too much amen and so so
think about that for a second she asked
how do you determine the line that for
me that tends to be the line and and
here's here's the cool part about that
but also the the frustrating part about
that maybe it's cool because it's
frustrating Ryan but if it feels like
too much today and then tomorrow it was
like too little well no no it it may not
feel like too much today but a year from
now it may feel like too much and so
it's constantly scaling back or
simplifying or changing the line will
move over time right and the same is
true like if Ryan and I you and I are
getting ready to go out into some big
tour or whatever obviously gonna mention
that so we will promote it in fact I'll
use a different word we will market it
differently right mm-hmm and so she
asked though did being off social media
reveal any lack of value or value for
getting the word out about projects and
I would say yes and no I mean we we
announced this Los Angeles event which
by the time this comes out where our to
be done we're filming this documentary
called blesses now and that thing sold
out in three hours without social media
right but then here's the weird thing
this is the 7 p.m. show still had a few
tickets left and so we'll use social
media to help sell that event out as
well we're not going to beat people over
the head with it though and so so the
answer is yeah we may have missed out
slightly but you're not missing out on
as much as you think no it is yeah that
is one of the hugest lessons I learned
man is like it is really not that
relevant
it does help it does augment and it does
add value there's no doubt about it
but but it is you know life is totally
fine without it and we're so we're
bringing the the tour over to
Australia we're ending our lessons now
tour in Australia and March and I got an
update just recently and ticket sales
were just fine when we were off social
media now we'll use social media to
announce that hey we're coming over
there next month and and you can come
check us out but again it's it's going
to be the end credits it's not going to
be the plot of the film exactly Josh I
think it's amazing how you included
included fields and your answer there
here's like the answer for me any social
media is too much the question I try to
ask myself is how can I use this tool as
little as possible and still add value
to the various platforms people love so
what what I mean by that is this I hate
social media man like if you look at my
tweets compared to anybody else's tweets
man I mean it is like I'm like a fourth
or a third like I am I don't use it that
much yeah I use it well you know you had
talked about earlier about how there
were two ways to use social media and
ask communicate yeah so yeah so for me
it's I kind of look at it and maybe
we're saying the same thing I look at it
as you are either yes you're either
broadcasting you or you're saying
something on social media or you are
consuming mmm social media yes and for
me when I am creating when I am
broadcasting um like Twitter is my main
my main social media platform um for
broadcasting yes for consuming my main
platform is Instagram is Instagram yeah
so on Twitter when I broadcast I am
asking myself like okay yes is this
going to add value but more importantly
it has to do one of these three things I
am either I have something I want to
communicate like whether it's an event
or an article witty remark something
that I feel like is going to add value
whether it's informational or
entertaining right yes yeah both of
which add value entertaining could just
be funny absolutely so one of those
reasons it's when I have a question so I
love
I love going to Twitter yeah I did this
on Facebook a little bit and it did help
a lot because sometimes I got to get out
of my bubble sometimes like I am just I
am in too much of a bubble and I'm like
alright dude everyone who I hang out
with is telling me the same thing and
that's okay but I want to hear a
different perspective and a you know an
unbiased perspective from a multiple
bias for multiple biased perspectives
yeah dude so I love going to Twitter or
other platforms I've used before to to
posit a question that I really want to
get some a lot of feedback on but really
other than that man like I'm just going
through my feet and thinking about how I
use it I don't use it much much beyond
that man so again for me if I could if
we could not use social media and it had
not have such a huge impact on us if it
was neutral if it was neutral like we
wouldn't use it um it does have an
impact you know there isn't like a
percentage I could sit here and put on
it and say we reach we change this many
more lives when we use social media than
if we didn't like the you know it's
impossible to quantify that but I think
an even quantify to it to a lesser
extent you can look at like how many
people subscribe or visit the vlog I
should say and and podcast and other
creations versus how many people follow
us on social media and it's probably one
twentieth so 5 percent of the value of
what we do is you know because what do
we have a million 2 million people on
social media total across all platforms
sure and but we private wente million
people a year across all the other non
social media platforms and so if I look
at it that way I realize a quantifiable
I think so the question is I don't know
if people get the same value though so
like I think you get disproportionately
more value from say the podcast or the
blog when you do social media so it may
be the 5 percent of our audience is on
social media maybe it's even 10 percent
right 5 to 10 percent but then do they
get as much value as they do from the
other 90% and if you
that then what you can say is man we
should allocate five to ten percent of
our time on social media and the other
90% of the time creating which I feel
pretty good about that yeah I do two men
for sure I am I want to be clear like I
am I'm being a little hyperbolic right
with any social media it's too much like
when I was writing this out I was
thinking about like going to the gym if
I didn't have to go to the gym I
wouldn't mmm you know what I'm saying
yeah I mean for all intents and purposes
I hate going to the gym right but I love
what going to the gym gets me you you
love having gone to the gym I love
having gone to the gym right exactly and
that's how I kind of look at social
media like I don't really love social
media because it is an extra it's just a
thing that takes my time up right it's a
time suck it is whether it's good or bad
um we try to make it as good as possible
as much as possible right um but but the
point is is that I can go to social
media though and I can use it in a way
that is very inspiring or very helpful
adds a lot of value but just like going
to the gym dude you can go to the gym
too much and you can you can hurt
yourself working out too much absolutely
I mean you hear these stories of so many
CrossFitters who like they're just
starting CrossFit and they haven't they
used to be an athlete but they haven't
worked out in 10 years and they start
CrossFit because they have the motions
down or not all of a sudden people
thrown out their back and dropping
plates on their neck and all this crazy
stuff and you're like oh I'm doing this
wrong mm-hmm too much too soon too much
emphasis whatever and I think the same
is definitely true with social media all
right Mikey wants to know why return to
social media actually make your life
more meaningful or is it really just a
modern platform to advertise he has
advertising quotes there I believe I did
that with my inflection yeah you did and
in the radio business call that a vocal
quote as I'm talking about inflection
Josh has his hands above his head
flexing his biceps like bicep I just
have one so here's I fit the answer and
then we will talk about a little bit
a paintbrush can create a masterpiece a
paintbrush can destroy a masterpiece and
idle paintbrush however does nothing at
all and so the thing that I would just
talk about here is social media is a
tool and it can be both it could be
meaningful it can also be a platform to
advertise now I'm gonna read something
really quick from Derek Siver's a moment
ago I was talking about his book the
mindset of marketing your music which
he's reworking on I'll put a link to it
in the show notes this is real quick the
the title of this chapter is marketing
just means being considerate don't
confuse the word marketing with
advertising announcing spamming or
giving away branded crap really
marketing just means being considerate
marketing means making it easy for
people to notice you relate to you
remember you and tell their friends
about you marketing means listening for
what people need and creating something
surprisingly special for them marketing
means getting to know people making a
deeper connection and keeping in touch
all of these are just considerate
looking at things from the other
person's point of view and doing what's
best for them a lot of musicians say I
hate marketing so yeah if you thought
marketing meant turning off your
creativity spending lots of money and
being annoying then it's a good thing
you don't like that nobody likes that
just find creative ways to be
considerate that is the best marketing
you know it's funny the pithy answer I
wrote I've been writing my pithy answers
without looking at yours uh-huh
because they usually not usually but a
lot of times they descend up saying kind
of the same thing yeah one influences
the other writes anything has to be when
you write yours first yeah exactly so oh
that's why you switched him around I was
always wondering why you did that
oh really yeah because it used to be
yeah anyway so here's I hit the answer a
silent monk sitting in a temple convert
to no one hmm and it's it's just saying
the same thing that you said men someone
who has like a monk
look at the monk I really look up to
monks they got a lot of knowledge um
I've had some meaningful conversation
with monks I love talking about
spirituality I love talking about
beliefs I love talking about dogmatix
although all that stuff
although we don't talk about that on the
show cuz that's that's that's typic I
like having those conversations with
like one or two people right yeah in
private I don't like having those
conversations what's for you so going
back to what Michelle was talking about
earlier like that's a line you draw
probably you're not gonna talk about
spiritually because you feel like it
will take away from the greater good it
takes away from the goal arise people
because the tribe thing we were talking
about was and ER it's divisive and
that's not what I don't want to be
divisive right um but yeah but when I
think of a monk and how much I look up
to him one can why I look up to a monk
if I think of if every single monk ever
like just went to a monastery and was
silent and never left the monastery then
I never would have had the opportunity
to have a really cool conversation with
a monk yeah wouldn't serve the greater
good right exactly so you know I would
argue that people who who have an
amazing message or story that they
really want to get out there or
something that is going to add value to
a lot of people it's going to help in
some way they're kind of doing a
disservice by not saying anything yeah
yeah I think so and so that I think
that's the point why why return because
not returning would do a disservice to
our audience and the people who rely on
us to to whisper amongst the noise right
David Foster Wallace has this great
quote in one of his essays he talks
about a guy going to a Metallica concert
and whistling Mozart yeah and and that's
what we're trying to do sometimes it
feels like on social media it's pretty
loud man but we're just gonna come in
there calmly or speak softly and not
everyone's gonna hear us but hopefully
some of you will and I think that's
pretty great and III think that yeah
Mikey we're not advertising we don't do
advertisements we have done in the past
I don't think I'll do this ever
and maybe we will put we've done
promoted posts on Facebook but just to
our audience Facebook is its pay-to-play
right and so if we have I don't have any
people for us half a million people on
Facebook if you want to reach all of
them Facebook isn't like yeah it's go
and post something you can reach all of
them they make you pay to reach all of
them but we wouldn't just put up an ad
to say please target you know young
women in Alberta who want to you know
listen to podcast right but sometimes
it's just like we'll use MailChimp
occasionally to send out newsletters
from from our website you have to pay to
do that it's not free and it's just a
platform but we don't we never advertise
and so it isn't an advertisement and you
need to understand the difference
between marketing and advertising
marketing is being considerate as
Derrick silver says and that's what
we're trying to do the reason we return
is to be considerate and toward our
audience yeah it's just a little aside
man I was thinking about the stuff we
communicate on social media and I'm like
dude the Matt the vast majority of what
the minimalists advertise or whatever
you want to call it it's free it's stuff
you can get for free yeah yeah I mean so
if it's this if we're marketing this
podcast it's it's free well it's free
from most of you most of you are
freeloaders monetarily free but some of
you support us on patreon
you're not freeloaders if you don't if
you don't support us what yeah act
technically you are I mean that's that
that's the economic term for right it's
called the freeloader problem right yeah
I'm not judging anyone vote no I'm not
judging either I you're a freeloader I'm
okay with that
just dude my insecurities reflect the
mirror and so here's the way I go out of
my way I listen to a bunch of podcast
anytime I can support them monetarily
course or here's the other thing so
YouTube you know YouTube is my crack it
still is my crack right and the best $12
I spend every month is I spend $12 for
YouTube because it makes it a hundred
percent advertisement for YouTube red
well that's awesome
and I listen to YouTube quite often as
well yeah it's 12 bucks a month and it
cuts out every single hour that's why we
just watch those those video
the Martin Luther King thing earlier
there were no I had some puffed up
because I paid 12 bucks a month and I
can write from my phone it allows you to
not watch the video and just listen to
the audio cuz some podcasts are just
video podcasts and I'll listen to them
on YouTube and I can do it right from my
phone and there's never an advertisement
and so I'm willing to pay for those
advertisement free things and so you all
can can do that with this podcast well
if you can't afford it totally
understand you're welcome to be a
freeloader it's not a judgement it's
just it is the technical economic term
all right now it's time for our added
value portion of the shows where we each
talk about something that has added
value to our lives
recently I Ryan has anything added value
to your life recently
dude I picked up Columbia roast from
Blue Bottle yeah the other day uh well
do you know what I'm shocked by is they
were bought by Nestle they weren't
bought by Nestle yeah no I thought
Nestle just invested like bought a bunch
of stock like invested of air owned by
Nestle they're owned by Nestle and but
their quality hasn't changed though the
quality hasn't but the quantity has
changed right I mean they're more shops
popping up everywhere in West Hollywood
they're like three shops and so yeah so
a shop opened up about a block away from
my house I'm lucky if I can get in there
get beans oh yeah they keep very few
retail being it is like them so when I
say quantity like it's it's a hard to
get it's hard to get beans at a retail
store online is where is the best place
to get it but the good news of
California just legalized coffee and so
soon you'll be able to get more of it so
anyway go to Blue Bottle comm go to
single origins and there should be a
Columbia there that you can order their
stuff does go really quick like I was
saying so I'm yeah yeah I hope you can
get if you're a coffee lover I hope you
can get it because it's a yeah it is a
damn fine roast or if you're in the Bay
Area if you're in Los Angeles you're in
New York they have shops and all three
cities and they're coming to Boston and
Miami pretty soon - they got a couple
shops in New York for sure yeah yeah I
said if you're in you weren't paying
attention I said that no no you said the
Bay Area I was stuck on if you're a Bay
Area or LA or New York then you can go
in and get coffee right there I was
stuck on the West Coast man and then if
you if you go if you're in Miami or
Boston they should have a shop coming
soon anyway I think they're opening up a
shop in New York pretty soon okay
why yes right I'm glad you asked is
there something that added value to my
life recently so there I'm just you know
what did this portion of the podcast
uh-huh I'm assuming like 80% of people
shut their shut the podcast often we're
like let's go to the added value I get
so many comments of when we don't do an
added value segment how come you do not
value segment though you know there's
definitely a lot of people listen to it
still but it's just we can let loose a
little bit more here because I know that
80% of people have stopped listening at
this point it's okay so Cal Newport we
already mentioned him once but he he
wrote this article called Arnold
Bennett's fight against steampunk social
media and he he talks about this guy
Arnold Bennett he published a short
volume called how to live on 24 hours a
day which by the way is such a great
title how to live on 24 hours a day this
is in 1910 and he was alarmed with the
way the newly emergent British middle
class seemed to waste their time outside
of work
the average salary men in this era
doesn't live he noted but instead
muddles through wasting time and he he's
a little quote there that inexplicable
raw material of everything the supply of
which though gloriously regular is
cruelly restricted so he's really just
talking about how we're wasting all of
all of our time now this is the same
argument we put forth for social media
these days but if you read this essay I
won't go through the whole thing here
but he talks about how basically people
just come home from work and they they
just potter around right they they go
play a game of cards or or they're
basically just wasting their time and
we're doing the same thing with social
media and so maybe another question
asked ourselves is is this wasting my
time or even better is this the best use
of my time you know what dude but we've
got to we've got to be clear to those
that like it's okay to waste time
sometimes yes madad to give ourselves
permission to waste time right like it's
it's just a balance of lake we want to
create but we also got to relax
mmm-hmm so it's like wasting as little
time as possible
but still be okay with wasting a little
bit and so maybe again the best question
acid is this the best use of my yeah
right yeah and sometimes wasting your
time is the best it is you know if your
time yeah absolutely it's not let's be
clear
of course wasting 23 hours a day not
advisable right being able to discern
when it is okay to waste your time
that's that's what we're all striving
for man I still don't know what if I'm
wasting my time properly I'd you know in
treatment maybe as a reward sometimes
it's great to I know I do that with my
crack YouTube and like I will schedule
it and say okay if I've accomplished
what I want to accomplish you need to
get through all these things write this
essay whatever I'll give myself
permission to go on YouTube for an hour
and and sort of veg out waste that time
productively or intentionally
intentionally wasting time which isn't a
waste at all there's something pithy in
there for you Sean anyway I got a couple
more recommendations here because they
all sort of go together I already talked
about the Center for humane technology
they have a page on there called take
control it's about social media so let's
just talk about some of the things from
that we'll put a link to the full
article and the show notes so the Center
for Humane technology is started by
Tristan Harris a former ethicists at
Google and he's trying to help people
take control of their phone and here's
some simple changes it will help you
take care take control of your phone
turn off all notifications except from
people and notifications appear as red
dots because the red triggers that that
color triggers you instantly draws your
attention in basically and so he talks
about that and how it turned off all of
your notifications go grayscale on your
phone I know I've tried this in the past
and man it really helps it radically
reduces the amount of of twitching that
I do for my phone because it's less
exciting when it's all in grayscale
right let's see he's in the next tip
here is try keeping your homescreen on
tools only and he shows a little like a
little setup here of how to only have
the tools there so your notepad your GPS
bottom right maybe your voice memo while
here I'll show you the picture here he
has a set up really interesting that's
awesome dude I'm not trying to one-up
him yeah
has my home screen has only those four
things at the bottom yeah no totally and
and I think this is a nice like step in
between right where where you have only
the tools on your phone for me a Kindle
app would be on there your calendar
might be on there so he shows you how to
do that launch other apps by typing so
if you really want to go to Instagram
force yourself to scroll down type in
the word Instagram and force you to
think a little bit instead of mindlessly
swiping to find to find that icon right
yeah actually going in and typing in the
name charge your device outside the
bedroom he talks about why that's
important go cold turkey remove social
media from your phone that's one of the
things we did in January for sure just
have all those icons gone and I found
myself twitching forward at first but
then of course when you can't switch for
it you find something else to replace it
with hopefully it's maybe a Kindle app
or something more more useful yeah this
one was interesting that you and I
actually do this occasionally Ryan send
audio notes or call instead of texting
we will often send audio notes special
it's like and the reason he says that is
the studies show it's common for people
to misinterpret text messages now as a
writer the thing that I try to do is
make my text messages more clear right
in fact it's one of the things I teach
my writing students in the how to write
better writing class is I say don't use
emojis because if you use your
vocabulary correctly you you can you can
do better than an emoji right you can do
better at communicating yeah and so but
although although in the same token an
emoji can communicate so many words with
just the picture it absolutely can but
if you're trying my point is if you're
trying to improve your writing
how can you I'm with you how can you
create that if there was an appropriate
time your emoji in the right
inappropriate time for not an emoji
right I agree with you the majority of
the time it's probably not appropriate
actually in texting maybe it's maybe
it's appropriate more there but I'm
certain like a professional setting I
guess is right right yeah yeah
absolutely but the when you're trying to
improve your writing one of the things I
encourage people to do is avoid those
little shortcuts right but I like this
if we're just trying to communicate with
each other and we don't want to be
missed
interpreted via text message because of
tone or whatever you can you can have
tone in a little voice memo you send
over to someone so salutely send that
audio note instead of sending the text
and then he has texting shortcut here
use quick reactions and so he talks
about that and then there's a bunch of
other resources there at the Center for
Humane Technology it's their take
control page over there and then two
other things that sort of go together
there's a podcast I listen to
occasionally I've got Shawn listening to
it now I think Beck's listen to it you
know I love music I'm really into music
there's New York Times pop cast is what
it's called and the critic on there his
name is Jon Caramanica and one week
he'll put out an episode about jazz
music and the next week we'll put out an
episode about yeah little peep and the
new soundcloud rappers man is where the
little peep has been mentioned now on
the two podcasts in a row will may he
rest in peace yes and and he'll talk but
he talks about this music with such
nuance he can go through a little peep
album the same way he can go through a
John Coltrane album mmm Jon Caramanica
is sort of a savant of owning hearing
review of mumble rap album yeah that's
the mean little people a little buzz
moment effectively mumble rap yeah and
man he's good at both but then he did
this episode recently on how some of the
best writers in 2018 and in music are
female writers and female bands and he
introduced me to this new band called
snail mail and they have this EP that
came out in 2016 it's the only work
that's out there right now alright so
I've been finding value in that EP
apparently snail mail has an album
coming out hopefully this year it really
is some of the best writing that that
I've heard in music recently so check
out the pop the pop cast if you're
looking for a new podcast listen to and
if you like music and then also if you
like music check out snail mails habit
EP all right let's move on real quick to
right here right now so we talked about
what is going on in the lives of the
minimalists so Ryan Josh let's talk
about what's going on in our lives
what do we got going on we got Australia
we do but first a lot of people been
asking asking me about my health I've
been talking a little bit about my
health
eventually I within the next few months
hopefully I will do a podcast or maybe a
series of podcasts talking about how I
got rid of my back pain which I
struggled with desperately I mean it was
ten out of ten pain for awhile so well
hopefully do it I decide we're gonna
have to cancel our tour in 2014 you look
so bad yeah yeah so so we'll deal with
that I'll try to deal with some of the
other problems I had really bad gut
problems with fixed mercury poisoning
I'm gonna try to bring one of my doctors
in here to talk about from nourish
nourish balance thrive because Chris
Kelly
Christopher Kelly have him come in and
maybe talk about and maybe go over some
my tests and some of them would be
helpful for other people and also talk
about things I'm still struggling with
health health-wise like my multiple
chemical sensitivities did you get the
mold tests back in I haven't gotten back
yet we did a mold test last week it
takes about ten days to get that back
but I've gone through so much I've
improved so much I've got a lot of room
to grow still and to improve but
hopefully I'll be able to do a podcast
episode detailing some of the health
stuff not to just pontificate about what
I've improved but I've really want to
help people I get questions all the time
about about how I improve certain things
about my health next week we've got a
podcast episode about emotions with
Courtney Carver so Courtney Carver is
gonna be in our new studio we're gonna
record a podcast episode with her we're
actually gonna be doing an intro for a
book tour stop she has here in Los
Angeles by the time this comes out that
will have already happened she has a new
book out called soulful simplicity all
you mentioned we're gonna be in
Australia so those are either sold-out
or really close to selling out in almost
all the cities we're going to Perth
Adelaide Brisbane Sydney Melbourne and
Oakland we have two stops in Melbourne
because that first one sold out I know
they're all getting pretty close so come
on out if you want in March to see us
live it's a lesson out or you can go to
the minimalists comm slash tour you can
find all the theaters dates and tickets
if they are still available if you want
the show notes to every single episode
that we we create we can send them to
you via email just go to our website the
minimalists com
typing your email address at the top
we'll send you any new podcast episodes
all the show notes everything we
mentioned
also any new essays that we that we
publish anything that we write you'll
get there for free you also get some
occasional news updates from the
minimalist but of course will never ever
send you spam or junk or anything like
that no advertisements no pop-ups all
that stuff is no fun oh and this week on
our PostScript episode we're changing
the name Ryan from over time the
PostScript yeah
63 we went out on patreon and asked the
the folks on patreon it 63% voted for
PostScript 37 so they want to keep the
overtime so from here on out they aren't
over script over there over script
oh my god new poll or poll time just for
the record I don't care what we call it
okay so this week on our PostScript
episode we're gonna try to answer five
quick questions about social media the
first one is are you going to use your
personal accounts the same way as the
minimalists accounts and we're also
going to answer did you spend more time
on phone calls in place of social media
and did you enjoy that while you were
off what did you miss the most about
social media and is there any lingering
desire to cut it out entirely I think
you can be surprised by some of our
answers in some of these did your
relationship with people change because
of not using social media to connect my
answer to that is yes but not how you
might expect so what we'll cover that
why black and white photos on Instagram
but we'll talk about that too
and did you sleep better without having
social media and the short answer to
that one is yes and I think I'll tell
you why it may not be what you're
expecting but you can find that only on
for our patreon supporters over at the
minimalists comm you click on the donate
button at the top you can support us via
PayPal or Vimeo Vimeo venmo
PayPal or venmo and or you if you
support us on patreon you get access to
all of our bonus episodes we're calling
our PostScript episodes but also live
streams we even did a anti-consumerism
meditation a few months back and you'll
have access to all the old archives of
the minimalists private podcast now I
know what you're at home saying
I don't want to log on and have to
listen to your podcast on my computer
and I would say the same thing that
would suck I wouldn't want to support
the podcast I was the case but the
minimalist private podcast actually
shows up in your regular podcast feed
whatever you're listening to right now
if you're on Apple podcasts or Google or
or overcast or wherever all you need is
the private link from our patreon page
and it will show up every time we
publish a new PostScript episode every
week or if we publish something else
into that private feet all we do live
events as well so we have the
philadelphia event people were rioting
like crazy at our philadelphia van they
were breaking windows they were so happy
to see it's flipping cars over that's
how people in Philadelphia show their
their cheer and happiness their
appreciation your simplicity that's
right we also published the Tampa event
and also our Detroit event we've got
some other ones that are coming up as
well so live events that are exclusively
on the minimalist private podcast just
head on over to the minimalists com
click donate at the top if you're
interested in hearing more and hearing
our answers to all those questions also
we're going to do a a private tour for
our patreon supporters of our new studio
space since y'all paid for this space we
figured we'd give you the private video
tour we're still waiting on the lighting
to be installed we have to have a metal
fabricator change and stuff but once
that's in here we'll do a private tour
of our new studios but no offense
everyone else but it you know you
obviously don't care anyway because
you're freeloaders according to Josh
yeah and according to you know
economists know we appreciate the
freeloaders oh yes we do yeah I mean and
here's the thing I also realized that
not everyone can afford the support us
monetarily what we're trying to do is
create other meaningful creations for
the people who want to go out of their
way to support us but if you can't
support us that's ok it's totally ok
we're still looking we're gonna keep
giving this to your homeless and
advertisement free if you can't support
us with money by listening to our
podcast your social supporting us yeah
absolutely
so all you freeloaders you're still
supporting the hell out of us and we
thank you very much for it yes indeed
Josh and I will continue to support you
we assume well we'll continue to Purdue
meaningful creations will avoid content
creation and content generation and try
to record episodes that add value to
your life Ryan you got anything else
right here right now man I've got this
huge stack of voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners hi this message
is in response to Kelly who had a
question that you guys read on the
collecting podcast about being a wife
and mother to collectors and as a fellow
wife and mother to for collectors and
one husband collector I just wanted to
share what's worked in my life we try
and have a policy where shared spaces
family room/kitchen etc we keep pretty
minimal we keep our personal items out
of it and then in their own rooms they
have closets cupboards bookshelves where
they can house their collections and
when the collections begin to exceed
that or new collections come in then we
help them decide what they can take out
and replace and that helps them to think
about what they really have and use it
and if they're not using it then they're
typically willing to get rid of it at
least that works well for the children
and then for my husband he has places in
the basement where he can store things
that he's not willing to part with and
knowing those things are there does
drive me crazy but that's part of being
in a relationship and I just have to let
that go as long as it's not in my face
cluttering up the house I can live
peacefully and not be stressed out and
they can still have their collections
hey there this is Jesse from Germany and
I want to share a tip for decorations
there's art libraries in many places
which allow you to take home pieces of
art for a couple of weeks and that's
great for either having cool pieces of
art at home that cost almost nothing or
it's a good way to figure out what kind
of art fits your style before actually
purchasing anything
and my name is KB I'm from Melbourne I'm
really excited about seeing you in a few
weeks time I just had a tip for everyone
out there who also had collected
magazines and been hoarding them for a
few years such as myself high schools
really appreciate the donation if you
know a teacher or there's a local school
nearby
just ask the art teacher the fashion
teacher if they need some new magazines
for collaging when I was in high schools
as always one of my favorite activities
and not that easy to come by if you
don't want to buy them so just get them
out of your life unless you still read
them but chances are you probably don't
all right Joe that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also email a voice memo to podcast
at the minimalists comm and if you leave
here with just one message we hope
what's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time